hello I'm Deborah con and I moderated
today's session on asia's consumer
dilemma a lot of bad statistics out
there namely that in the next 50 years
six billion people will be living in
urban populations right now over two
billion people are emerging consumers
emerging meaning they didn't have money
to spend in the past but now they do
have money and Asia's mil class is
actually the fastest growing population
one of the fastest in the world so faced
with all of these things what are some
of the sustainable practices that we can
be put in it can be put in place
interestingly enough it came down to
basics right changing people's behaviors
like I remember growing up in California
where there was a big drought and never
really and that really reinforced good
practice for me in terms of saving water
and a colleague and somebody spoke about
Japan and how Japan is really today
putting in place a system whereby new
after the tsunami they know they're
going to be faced with massive energy
shortages well what they're doing is
they've someone an entrepreneur has
created a program which will alert
people as to when they should shut off
their air conditioners in order to you
know promote good practice so a lot of
those types of things came up as well as
how the government and business can
proactively work together some of the
issues infrastructure problems in India
alone forty percent of all food is
wasted mainly due to infrastructure
problems and not being able to transport
it in a good way so we focused on really
kind of what you can do at the micro
level and some of the business leaders
have already put good practice in you
know in their csr programs but they
really one of the big messages is that
they really need the government's help
as well so with that I think the core
the one thing that everybody did agree
on was education and how important it is
to educate from a very young level
age as well as at the beginning of the
production line so you know enforcing
good practices with like in the factory
workers and to make a change at the
bottom in order to have significant
change at the top so that was about it
what we learned and ok and now all
there's my question and the question I
have chosen to answer is what is the
fundamental power that people have that
will transform our world and I believe
actually it's the ability to communicate
well because if you you might have a
good idea but it's the way that you
communicate it to the most amount of
people that is probably going to enable
the most change 3d beginning even